impfen er bei diesem thema da kochen hin
und wieder die emotionen hoch und
manchmal da kochen die auch einfach über
in mexiko liefern fernsehmoderator
seinem frust über impfgegnern masken
verweigerer jetzt mal so richtig freien
lauf
kina kina
ja das gibt's aber auch auf deutsch so
viel emotionen so viel aufregung die
steckt hier in deutschland nämlich vor
allen dingen in der riesen diskussion um
die impfpflicht aktuell die impfpflicht
die mittlerweile aktuell immer mehr an
rückhalt verliert denn jetzt hauen auch
die ärzte dazwischen er die kassen ärzte
die sagen wir machen nicht mit wir
impfen keinen patienten gegen den willen
roms das ist ein schwerer schlag für
alle impfpflicht befürworter für kanzler
olaf scholz und gesundheitsminister
lauterbach der klammert sich noch an
diese impfpflicht
mein
weg in richtung des schutzes der
notwendige ist das mit prominenten
varianten im herbst nicht wirklich
kämpfen müssen ist die impfpflicht ja
also da wird daran festgehalten dass
schon mal auf die aktuellen zahlen ein
kleiner micon variante des corona virus
hierzulande ganz schön im griff die fall
seien in deutschland die steigen in
bislang nie da gewesener höhe zum ersten
mal liegen wir über 100.000 eine
neuinfektion des rk ii meldet 112 1323
neuinfektionen an einem tag aber die
krankenhaus incidents die sind weiter
neuen bundesländer liegen unter dem
grenzwert von 3 unter anderem bayern nrw
und aus sachsen kommt jetzt die
impfpflicht ergibt die sinn weil die
inzidenz wieder in die höhe schießen die
infektionszahlen oder er gibt die
überhaupt keinen sinn erst recht wenn
für die umsetzung der rückhalt der
kassen ärzte der praxisärzte jetzt auch
noch verloren geht darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit dem chef kassenärzte in
deutschland mit andreas gassen schönen
guten tag herr gassen guten morgen hallo
sagen sie uns einmal warum sie nicht
willens sind die impfpflicht diese
umstrittene sinn ist dann in ihren
praxen umzusetzen ja ich glaube ich muss
mal eins von vornherein klar machen also
die wir unterstützen ja die
impfkampagnen auch die booster kampagne
und das tun die die große zahl der
praxen über 80.000 nehmen eine
impfkampagne teil wenn man jetzt eine
impfpflicht etabliert und die diskussion
ist ja voll im schwange und da würden
wir uns auch gar nicht positionieren
wollen als pro oder contra denn es gibt
in der ärzteschaft durchaus stimmen
dafür und viele dagegen was wir aber
alle sehen ist die große logistische und
organisatorische herausforderung und uns
geht es nur darum zu sagen also zum
einen muss man eine struktur schaffen
die dann eine impfpflicht ja bei
impfwilligen umsetzen das können nicht
die praxen seien schon alleine weil sie
mit arbeit voll sind und zum zweiten ist
es natürlich für einen arzt oder eine
ärztin undenkbar jemand gegen seinen
willen zu impfen das ist aber mein
verständnis zumindest bisher nicht
geplant ich aber nicht denn etwas karl
lauterbach der nun selber mediziner ist
an solche szenarien denkt wir geben hier
mehr zu bedenken dass man wenn man eine
impfpflicht etabliert natürlich auch
weiß wie sie dann umzusetzen ist und die
praxen sind hier nicht die struktur die
hier in der pflicht sind deshalb müssen
wir uns hier mit der umsetzung der
impfpflicht an sich keine gedanken
machen wir impfen gehen der das gerne
möchte aber eine impfpflicht umsetzung
ist dann aus unserer sicht eher aufgabe
der öffentlichen hand und das wollten
wir an der stelle einfach mal klar
machen
natürlich nicht bei sich in den praxen
haben den ärger denn die die sich bisher
nicht haben impfen lassen die haben ja
ganz ganz persönliche ganz gründe die
sich sehr erwartet haben offenbar über
all die monate sie wollen diesen
konflikt natürlich nicht in den praxen
haben nämlich an nein das ist herr
laumann hat ja mal ein vorschlag gemacht
der im grundsatz nicht verkehrt ist dass
es ab bevor wir eine sanktion
aussprechen sollte jemand intensiv
beraten werden zur impfung das ist aber
eine sache die die praxen zwar auf
nachfrage der patienten gerne tun aber
dass wir jetzt sozusagen
nach einer impfung ladung leute die
unten impfen willig sind in die praxen
geschickt bekommen die da beraten werden
das ist er aber das was wir zeitlich gar
nicht schaffen würde und b auch etwas
was wir von unserer verständnis von
interaktion zwischen arzt und patient
nicht wollen also wir sind nicht
diejenigen die die institution sind oder
die organisation die nachher eine
impfpflicht
umsetzt wie gesagt alle impfkampagnen
wunderbar das unterstützen wir auch
gerne nur hier muss man sich glaube ich
tatsächlich gedanken machen wenn man
eine wie auch immer geartete impfpflicht
macht muss auch klar sein wie wird die
organisiert werden wer impft erklärt auf
und da sollte man bitte nicht die praxen
im hinterkopf haben denn die können und
wollen das nicht leisten was ist die
lösung ist lang sie vor
ich kann das offen gestanden in ad hoc
auch nicht sagen der minister hatte
gesagt er wäre nicht unbedingt ein fan
eines registers ich habe keine wirkliche
vorstellung die man 83 millionen
bezüglich ihres im status erfasst
einlädt dann nachher wenn man wo geimpft
wird aber
die wassergasse ich glaube es gibt dann
gar keine lösung wenn die kassen ärzte
nicht mitmachen ohne ihr bild ist gerade
eingefroren ich hoffe wir hören und
sehen sie gleich wer jetzt also glaube
es gibt gar keine lösung vergessen wenn
die kassen ärzte die mächtige lobby ja
auch gar nicht mitmacht wir sind jetzt
in der situation in der der widerstand
der der die befürworter in den reihen
des bundestags für die impfpflicht
offenbar langsam weniger werden und das
hat ja gute gründe wir wissen gar nicht
mit welchem impfstoff diese impfpflicht
überhaupt umgesetzt werden soll
umgesetzt werden kann wir wissen gar
nicht wie ob mit imf register ja oder
nein und jetzt wissen wir noch nicht mal
mehr wer überhaupt impfen soll das heißt
die impfpflicht ist doch eigentlich tot
die können wir heute bei bild live
begraben wie soll das funktionieren ohne
sie
also die impfpflicht ist bleibt eine
politische entscheidung wir sind im
grundsatz da als player auch nicht drin
und von daher ging es uns nur darum noch
mal deutlich zu machen dass man nicht
vielleicht insgeheim im hinterkopf daran
denken wir machen eine impfpflicht und
dann wird das in den praxen schon
irgendwie exekutiert das wird so nicht
funktionieren deshalb ist diese frage
einfach eine ganz blöde organisatorische
und die muss natürlich beantwortet sein
wenn man eigentlich machen wird und die
auch in irgendeiner form früchte tragen
soll unabhängig davon plädieren wir
natürlich nach wie vor dafür die
impfkampagne weiter vorn laufen zu
lassen und die ist er höher nicht so
ohne erfolg
aber es ist eben alles nicht völlig
trivial und wir sind einfach ein
bisschen
erschrocken gewesen als die ersten
gespräche in die richtung gehen dass man
ja dann patienten zur aufklärung
vielleicht in die praxis schicken könnte
und das wird so nicht funktionieren ja
nur ohne sie wird nicht funktionieren
das kann man auch festhalten oder wenn
die kassen ärzte nicht mitmachen bei der
umsetzung dann ist das ding tod das
funktioniert nicht oder haben sie
irgendetwas im gesundheitssystem mal
miterlebt in den letzten jahrzehnten was
funktioniert hat wenn die kassen ärzte
nicht mitmachen na gut also eine
impfpflicht ist eine aufgabe der
öffentlichen hand würde ich sagen das
ist dann möglicherweise was für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst wurde an
menschen für ihre verpflichten ist oft
das gespräch hingeschickt werden oder im
zweifel guten image waren wird es
möglicherweise nicht geben die dann auch
für eine impfung die sie nolens volens
über sich ergehen lassen aber das sollte
tatsächlich klar definiert sein und
das ist jetzt nichts was wir in der
aufgabe der niedergelassenen praxen
sehen die natürlich davon leben das ist
ein sehr tiefes vertrauensverhältnis
zwischen kolleginnen kollegen und den
patienten gibt und das wollen wir
natürlich auch nicht belasten sagte
andreas gassen kassenärzte chef vielen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch danke